burns are skin injuries
caused by heat
chemicals electricity or radiation your
doctor will recommend treatment based
on the size of your burn and the layers
of skin affected by the burn the
skin has three main layers the
epidermis the dermis and the hypodermis  o
subcutaneous layer containing fat blood
vessels and nerves under the skin
there are tissues such as facial muscles and
bones first degree or
superficial burns only affect the epidermis
the style of the burn appears red and
dry without blisters and slight pain is felt
second-degree or
partial-thickness burns involve the epidermis and parts
of the upper and lower dermis
the burn site is red and
moist and may
blister swelling and
severe pain third-degree or thick burns
completely spread throughout
the dermis and reach the hypodermis
the site of the burn appears with  an
uneven color ranging from white to
brown with a dry, leathery texture
as the burn is very deep causes
little or no pain
fourth degree burns involve the destruction of
all layers of skin and
sometimes extend to muscle
or  underlying bone these burns are
brown dry charred and almost
always painless you
can treat a first degree burn by
soaking in cold water for a
few minutes to soothe and protect
the tissue apply an antibiotic ointment
and cover as a clean dry
bandage you can take acetaminophen or ibuprofen
for pain
treat a second degree burn by
soaking in cold water for several
minutes apply an antibiotic ointment
to prevent infection and cover
with a clean, dry,
non-stick bandage change the bandage every
day and make sure your hands are
clean  Acetaminophen or ibuprofen
can help with pain and
swelling if you have a sunburn.
third or fourth degree go
to an emergency department immediately
if possible elevate the
burned part of your body to a position
higher than your heart you should also
seek medical attention if your burn
is larger than three inches in diameter
or is located on your  face hands feet
groin
buttocks or over a major joint